foreign
[Music]
what's up Austin it's good to be here my
name is Hans Kim we're gonna have a
dating show where we watch people date
each other it's gonna be awesome one of
my favorite things is watching a married
woman date uh guy uh which happens a lot
here
um so yeah if you're in a relationship
you can still go on a date
um yeah it should be fun we're gonna see
a lot of different combinations of
people uh we got a guest on the show
very funny guy uh he is a dating expert
he's an Asian man that has married a
white woman uh give it up for Michael
Ridley
[Applause]
Michael Ridley what's good Hans well
it's a good creep hard mode huh huh
what'd you say nothing okay hi
so how is your white wife she's white
she's my wife
she's uh she's 1500 miles away in
Virginia right now that's where I'm from
I left her in Virginia well that's a
good place to leave white women
no they feel safe there I guess I miss
her at the park
you miss her what do you miss most about
your white girl wife her white vagina oh
yeah
is it white it's pink
that's cool yeah it's good no it's
vaginas our Asian vaginas pink no
they're like uh burgundy
yeah they're burgundy I swear to God
that's gross
well shout outs to the white women their
vaginas are aesthetically more pleasing
just kidding no scientific research was
done
to back up that claim so we're gonna
pick two names there's only two names in
here uh please sign up or else it's
going to be a very deep dive into these
two people
uh we got carbon
straight female coming up
here she comes from the center table
give an upper Carmen one more time y'all
and Marco Marco here he comes hopefully
he'll find his Polo today yeah
right around the stairs around the side
one up to go on a date for one minute
and then we interview you
thank you for signing up
the more the merrier
Carmen and Marco going on a date for one
minute
interesting what could happen starting
now one minute nice to meet you Carmen
I have to ask why I mean I got my own
answer I'll happily provided but
um
you know I'm kind of you know I'm you
know this is scary it's a props for
doing it
why am I up here like yes yeah yeah so
yeah like I like I guess okay yeah yeah
that is very big yeah so like why why is
the universe yeah there's a lot of
questions
I I know I guess the one minute thing is
but
hi my name is Carmen from Austin where
are you from uh I live in San Antonio
but originally I'm From Italy really
yeah yeah born and raised I didn't uh
been land in this uh great uh place of
yours until uh 1998. love it we're in
Italy uh China uh for uh right on the on
the coast uh with uh you know on the
Mediterranean for a for way too long I
used to be proud to be in the birthplace
of uh Christopher Columbus but now I
know better yeah and time
give it up for Marco and Carmen
Marco's starting out with an age-old
question why
you don't you don't do any small talk do
you you get right to the philosophical
Bedrock of your Italian forebearers
yeah you know that I that's kind of like
my thing like nothing can be simple no
you know like what what is the Paradigm
Underneath It Whatever the force is
controlling it how can happen yeah no
wonder you guys take so many breaks when
you're in your work day is thinking
about things over there you're like the
human equivalent of life is a simulation
and nothing matters
that ain't that the truth
so why work hey take another break
uh Carmen how's your dating life been
are you an Austin native pick up the mic
and just let them
uh I say that until someone calls me out
I'm originally from Elgin
oh [ __ ] not Elgin
you know what that means sausage Capital
Texas
there was a sausage Queen
I was
wondering yo give it up for the [ __ ]
sausage queen or wherever the [ __ ] she's
from Texas
[Music]
wait what was the question again uh so
how's the dating how does your dating
life been 30 and single in Austin is
pretty hard so
what
uh giving up on the dating app so going
out to meet people in like real settings
so it's picking up that's cool I'm back
to the old school way of doing things
what do you think of this uh strapping
young Conquistador that's in front of
you I never meet a lot of Italians in
Texas so pretty cool I've only been in
Italy for 24 hours and that's it so I
need to go back yes you do I'm glad you
were there do you have property in Italy
Margo
my parents knew so noon
listen you go with Margo you can get
your cheese clapped in Sicily or
wherever the [ __ ] he's from it's just
mama and papa will be downstairs making
a pizza pie all right you guys will be
upstairs making a different kind of pie
hopefully
Mama's cooking is is uh is uh is very
good and I'm sure Papa would be very
proud nice okay and a whole family
involved
and that's the Italian way yeah
no Marco like this like this you're
doing it wrong I don't know what the
[ __ ] that was what accent was that all
right cool
that was racist I feel like
I I I spent my first 10 years not doing
the
especially you know first five years on
the phone and another five years in
person they're very handsy people yeah
lots of Handy modes yeah no I've I've
tried really hard to be American and now
I've I think I got it I got it to where
I like it you know like just the right
Blends cheeseburgers and Bud Light baby
that's all you need I I actually I like
my cheeseburgers with fresh mozzarella
on top no lie all right
so Marco you have a very interesting
Vibe about you you're like the Italian
Neil deGrasse Tyson I think I I I'm
flattered right now I mean I mean some
of the Twitter comments maybe not so
much but in general I'm pretty flattered
thank you okay you're on Twitter
no but uh he turns out he's cringy
enough to Transcendence
okay yes what do you what do you have to
say about that Carmen I think he's right
he's on
I think on Twitter and everything like
that that's kind of it's
a modern day
but wow digital news with the 30 year
old single woman from Austin
I'm on Twitter but I'm not active how
about that an inactive Twitter user
so Russia bought
um Carmen what do you think about uh
Austin and the dating scene here do you
enjoy it or hate it
um
what is uh what have you been doing
around paddle boarding and bird
scootering
okay
um
what have I been doing you know
I used to try to go a lot of
this is here we have a lot of people
look at me on everything it's like I
know yeah that's part of the show
um give her some words of encouragement
guys so she can get through this there
we go doing different things where we
can meet people uh I don't know going
dancing going sports bars uh
working out
that's fun yeah Marco do you uh do you
work out
I I have a Planet Fitness membership
mostly for the massage chair and the
planet
that's right okay around
what uh what do you do at the Planet
Fitness
about just the lounging a massage chair
coins in there for the full 10 minutes
where does the fitness part come in oh
oh no oh that's uh that comes elsewhere
I don't know I mean you live in a like
an Italian you have like a big big
machine guy you're on the machines right
for like 10 minutes maybe you wipe your
brow you you do a couple of these videos
Italian Bigfoot yeah but back in the day
I was uh I was a a rower in much better
shape and uh yeah did all the rower yeah
like a crew like you know skinny birds
yeah what was your favorite pick-up line
back in those days what would you say if
you saw someone
I I said enough and I mean thank God for
the Yahoo chat I mean honestly all you
got to do is speak Italian and whether
it be smooth or not I'm sure it's going
to come out great
what's your problem
gushing gushing wet y'all you should
have tried the angel question why go to
church
I know
it's the best pickup line that you've
ever heard
Carmen
all right
I'm an unknown Legend
you're in a legend I know Legend You're
an unknown Legend
were you [ __ ] a guy who does a lot of
mushrooms or something like those guys
came up and you wrote it on a napkin and
he slid it to me with his number oh so
he's autistic
Samurai Australian thing to say yeah
you're Unknown Legend Sheila
what
happened with that
with the legend man
legendary man
yeah big he had a big cork didn't he
all right all right so I just wanted to
say that I'm very shy about being on
stage that's not answer any questions
like
what kind of sex positions do you like
better mic this time
this uh give it up for the hardest
working AV man in Austin Texas is Nick
Roche
he's already [ __ ] up
he worked so hard oh what a gentleman
y'all thank you share your microphones
gentlemen have some chivalry for God's
sake okay what was the question again
what was the question I can't [ __ ]
remember dude you were a [ __ ] someone
and then oh yeah he didn't like last a
long time in bed no I'm in the
relationship it was kind of just one of
those Austin flings yeah the situation
shifts you know it's not like one of
those elegant relationships
that Hometown love I still have that I'd
be married with three kids but you know
girls on yeah yeah this is 2022. we
don't have kids monogamy is dead
I agree
yeah right it's good to be that way yeah
it's good to pop out a couple kids
uh but that's cool so you have a uh
short awesome you don't like the like
the modern liberal event and like the
[ __ ] whatever you know yeah yeah what
kind of guys do you like is what he's
asking
want to be Cowboys okay well I'm married
so
so anyone uh who can like try to be a
part of it is like let me teach you how
to dance
polka have some fun
go out and be the outdoors still
Adventure but nice just take it in but
not try to change the city yeah and then
you know if you're not from here yeah
don't get vaccinated Marco uh do you
want to learn uh you want to learn a
two-step
wow
[Music]
I think his two steps are a little
bigger than most people's two steps this
is a hodar of Italy
luckily my Crocs are pretty soft so when
I inevitably stuck peroxide
[Music]
an Italian hippie in Austin that's
pretty rational
[Applause]
this is like watching a school play
about what a date it's supposed to go
like
I I mean it probably says a lot about my
emotional maturity and dating skills but
yeah however have you ever fought a man
over a woman
like over the phone
no no I'm talking about the old
no no you ever order a pizza to a man
and seeing a girl that you're interested
in just to [ __ ] with it
that seems
very uh specific in that you know your
own answer might be UBS but uh no I
haven't well you said over the phone is
that something that actually happened
did you actually fight with someone over
the phone well I I told them to leave
her alone and then you know proceeded to
marry a woman
nice yeah sorry wrong but I mean I I
[ __ ] up that marriage so amazing grace
you know damn
you [ __ ] it up on your own yeah
but keep your hands off my woman I'm
gonna [ __ ] it up yeah you know really
like I mean like no I mean
he was like coming out of jail for not
paying child support so I mean like I I
was a I was a better [ __ ] up for her I
mean the next guy has a restraining
order against her so like oh well that
her [ __ ] up some like The Shining [ __ ]
up yeah like the guy that was like I'm
tired of these bad boys I just want a
nice accountant
yeah I mean very strong accounting
energy coming up
I I can do some arrangements right now
yeah I can see math just floating around
your head
okay
so so much easier than emotions you know
that math makes sense autism confirmed
y'all
the the finally the diagnosis that the
professionals have never reward me with
well we are Asian and doctors that's
kind of things want to know
Carmen you're obviously not autistic
you're voting enough for all four of us
on stage uh have you ever dated an
autistic man a young Sheldon
foreign
[Music]
autism radar went off
like a geiger counter
it's not like a game changer or
something like that I'm open but what's
the weirdest thing that an autistic
guy's done on a date
[Music]
Marco take notes
well it's a shame I retired my drone
collection that would be a great person
yeah oh [ __ ] hell yeah dude have you
ever there's one guy wearing games the
one I'm thinking of and I don't know why
it bugged me so much we were at a nice
dinner and he kept ordering Dr Pepper
oh yes one more Dr Pepper please thank
you and there's a couple other side of
Cheetos and he kept on me just doesn't
like wine because he doesn't like the
taste same coffee he just kept ordering
a ton of Dr Pepper
no wine for me please only Dr Pepper
just like that they have these glasses
on
[Laughter]
how often did he mention that he didn't
like the taste of wine every time I took
a sip
so don't try to do any weird personality
quirks on our first date no it's going
to be a normal person as much that
wasn't a match or a second date but um
got a good meal out of it nice you
deserve that's feminism yeah
what's the weirdest thing that you've
done on a date
well that's a good question and I don't
have a good answer for
anything weird that your date did that
you sticks out to you
yeah don't blinking this is the first
time you're blanking explaining emotions
oh yeah yeah I mean take notes you know
like but uh
yeah I'll just plead the fifth on this
one sorry guys wow what a normal normal
life you've probably lived probably now
totally normal you know what I mean what
do you think about what is your game of
choice or what is your uh thing that you
you obsess over the most
oh that's a good question please don't
say carbon
[Laughter]
all right so the second thing uh
thank you thank you uh let's see I I go
in phases uh like uh I I really like
watching boats go through I was gonna
say it has to be some kind of form of
transportation
thank God you're good I mean okay
this is the son of Columbus right now I
just love to see a boat going towards
brown people
so much gold
I have built my own boat I mean it just
sucked and it was too heavy to put on
top of my car so I never I don't know if
it floats but uh
but yeah so I've been in you know I grew
up by the Sea it's a real boat so yeah
what do you do for work uh
um I mean like delivery driver like I'm
delivering your fast foods like a yeah
I'm gonna help you okay you're doing the
Austin
uh gig economy
lifestyle you you guys got some juicy
gig economy up here and I'll I'll get
all you crypto people are hungry and I'm
I'm hungry to feed you yeah completely
you know appropriate five-star rating
kind of way
good job man you're really an American
American Dream live in it you know like
that yeah like that's that's like that's
kind of my thing like I've been you know
like following my dreams even if they're
like really weird and like it looks like
you know I couldn't believe like
aberration of a life from a distance
yeah yeah
um I was actually living in a van that
van life
so that's cool I too was homeless
Carmen have you ever been homeless
before
hell no
prove me wrong
I had to live at my aunt's guest house
for the white version of homelessness
y'all
coming you must you may stay in the
guest bedroom
it's got its own bathroom and a shower
that Elgin privilege right there yeah
what why were you in your aunt's guest
room what what did you do you were
caught shoplifting yeah yeah
one lease ended at a time and then my
next apartment was like a month out and
so
I had a really good so many places just
in between while they were doing
renovations do you guys have any even
better yeah do you have any pets guys
uh too much responsibility although I
did take care of it uh stud kit so so
that's all responsibility
since you had the last one to death
right
say that one more time have you seen The
Grapes of Wrath oh they're so soft I
love it yeah yeah it's very heavy-handed
I'll listen to the backyard they're very
strong looking man uh and very I hope
you don't take it the wrong way but uh
yeah what uh what about
what are you saying right now
I'm saying that he looked like uh Lenny
from Mice and Men or whatever
I'll I'll take it you know
you know I'm special in my own way and
and Lenny seems like a good dude in some
pretty [ __ ] up circumstance
two living creatures
anyways
oh man I don't want to blank on this one
I want to sound culture but I can't see
what because I can't use any of this
lineback's worth and I [ __ ] it I did uh
books do you read books
really big into audiobooks oh hell yeah
you guys finally got tapes in Elgin
I'm just kidding I'm sure you have a
very robust Public Library System
I mean it barely taught us how to read
so
I've made it far enough the hell you
talking about there ain't no goddamn
pictures in them
you made a doctor you're safe now
uh how many times did you watch Gone
With the Wind there was a Georgia thing
it's Texas but that's true I mean
the Alamo Margo yeah no Alamo how is
what was your sex ed like in to the
Texas public education system
they separated the boys and the girls
and a lot of it was just abstinence and
don't touch each other like that was
really Gonna Make a Difference
um
now if it feels good it's probably bad
honestly I can only remember one thing
from like
like a sex ed class and it was my
freshman year of college I was taking
like a health
class so you had to have like a like a
gym class and then help with me
teacher was telling us this story how
she used to work for the hotline at
college for the help and this guy calls
it and he's like man can you give me sex
and it just hurts real bad and she's
like okay well walk me through it was
like put on a condom and it just hurts
real real bad
she was like well really like you know
walk me through it he was like well can
I take it I roll it down the shaft I put
it over my balls and then
oh my gosh so
that was probably my biggest lesson I
learned from sex ed don't put the condom
over the balls they don't pop them in
all weird like shotgun shells
God damn
ouch yeah Marco you don't look like a
guy that uses condoms mark them out here
raw dogging it dude
using the pull out method
they don't know how to take it out of
the oven you know what I'm saying
we do have you know good health care and
access to abortion because human rights
but uh oh yeah just kill them babies
that's right
better than the alternative
and uh
uh but uh no I I believe in condoms and
I believe you believe in god what are
they [ __ ] aliens dog
I believe how condoms have have made the
world they're Freer and better place for
uh mediocre sex
events that make you not say catch HIV
uh you know to be extra safe right I
have time to be alive okay didn't know
that was a worry for you HIV but it is
no okay you are an Austin hippie yeah
what uh say HIV you know uh
sex iuds you ever you uh you ever have
any kids
uh not not on my own but I I do have a a
song you know son to me that that I I
take care you know also uh autistic you
know uh and uh yeah nice big step in and
pick up the pieces kind of guy that's
good man you know like [ __ ] yeah man
like uh like his own dad often self and
like uh like I yeah yeah just keeping it
happy for you guys at a comedy show
aren't you Brad yeah but but no no like
I'm yeah I'm greatly reducing his odds
of him committing suicide himself so I'm
possibly saving a life only important
thing I've ever done so far
thank you I feel privileged
is lowering his blood pressure and
providing him with endorphins so you're
getting something out of it
I'm stretching out my life expectancy
tremendously and here's my greatest
child and not dying alone I'm very
grateful
wait till you start sucking his blood
out and uh injecting it into your body
but it's just blood oh no never mind I
would never do that
anyways uh
do we really have to go deeper into you
now we only have two more names in the
bucket
uh Carmen what do you have any children
or do you want children what are your
opinions on children
um no I do not have any children
open to children
but
see what see where that takes me I don't
think my life's gonna be any less less
like unfulfilled if I don't have them
but always
yeah I mean see what happens people
really seem to like him up
here's this guy again
he's always [ __ ] with the mice thank
you Nick I do have a list of baby names
so but we'll see what happens there was
a giant baby on stage just now
[Music]
that's cool
um so do you think that uh you know like
your baby you would like put in the
Montessori or like would you be more
like a public school kind of child
public school oh yeah well I don't know
I mean I lived in Elgin you'd probably
go back into the private school but
Austin ISD I would definitely be public
that's a good call
uh he can get familiar with all these
liberal [ __ ]
learn how to dominate them
just be the chat amongst virgins
yeah you know how to answer them again
what's uh what baby names you got and I
uh what what name like three of them off
the top no I don't do that you don't
have it you said you had some baby names
you never share your baby names because
even if Jackson Braxton and oh no no no
no no no I might be from Elgin but I
definitely
all right hell yeah
yeah we're not doing any like Kayla Lynn
or like anything like that no um but I
have the thing is you never tell your
baby name because subconsciously your
friend steals it they might not remember
you telling the name but no you just
don't resent it oh it's happened I do
prison
Being Human and acknowledging feelings I
still I I could be Petty I was just
proud of her name making abilities what
was your name Marco if he wasn't named
Marco
laughs
Apollo
hello he's very close to Marco
gives up big Frank energy doesn't he
doesn't he look like he showed up to a
house party oh [ __ ] Frank's here dude
he's here to fix the internet
thank you yeah no problem Frank
what uh what's your internet speeds like
um
whatever Cricket thinks I should get
which sometimes zero [ __ ] uh but you
said Cricket yeah prepaid
you have an Android
yeah
I embrace it I am proud of your citizen
of the world my phone where I cannot
download an APK where it skips my ads if
I wanted wanted into two and and my
phone manufacturer and my OS developer
are okay with it well Carmen just got a
super wet just now Carmen you have an
idea
take notes
she has an iPhone y'all yeah so yeah
sorry I mean I I
you know big respects
you know that's cool you got it I found
you know a lot of terms around it
um so that's cool what uh what are you
gonna do after the show maybe you and
Carmen can go you know honky-talkie
do a little two-step yeah teach them how
to dance Carmen he's really stiff he
seems stiff
I suck at flexibility so I mean you're
not wrong yeah uh
that's right you know thank you yeah I
gotta set a lounging around yeah
getting your Mounds rubbed by that chair
get on that machine baby
you know I just have to enjoy it you
know like she almost sweaty people
having a bad time I mean they look great
don't get me wrong I wish I looked like
them I just don't want to do that kind
of work
uh wrist deep in that Tootsie Roll Bowl
that's so comfy I love it come on
Fridays for the free pizza
all right I was mourning when they took
it away well will be morning your loss
um of not being on the show anymore but
it was a blessing to have you while you
were here it's Marco and Carmen give it
up for him
exchange numbers
we'll meet each other that was good is
that good guys I feel like that was
really good we got straight female named
Rachel coming up
Rachel
Rachel is in the bathroom she's gonna be
nice and ready for this date
I can't have any bathroom breaks I also
know she's faking it oh here she is
Rachel going on a date with a straight
man named Daniel
oh Rachel and Daniel everybody here he
comes Daniel from the third row
[Music]
Rachel and Daniel
hi how's it going hi Daniel how's your
evening
um
actually we're watching the Packers
Cowboys game quite closely
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where are you from I live in San
Francisco
okay so what's your beef Wisconsin
um
[Music]
okay
um your politics are always
inconsistent and time let's stop it
right there it's Rachel and Daniel
going on a date
Milwaukee and this is San Francisco over
here a little Trump versus Clinton
action tonight are you even associated
with Trump yes I do not
um too late
the bar is low the bar is low
all of our for not being drunk yeah
well that's cool are you actually
watching the game or are you watching a
score no just like the play-by-play-up
thing I'm not sure if it would be better
if it was just a bit
so this is what just a bit that you were
doing watching football game this is
definitely doing it conspicuously he
wants us to know
you'd rather be
wearing a cheesehead
well you know you look like you were in
the military were you ever in the
military uh no
[Music]
you do look like you do look like you'd
be in Hitler's military Jesus Christ
they're a very beautiful Aryan man yes
we're Asian we can say that like
what part of uh the Fatherland are you
from
from Milwaukee Wisconsin the north side
so what part of Germany is that
you know there are a lot of German
immigrants there do you like schnitzel
I'm just gonna keep asking you questions
as if you're no no you know are you
German do you have German money Dutch
yeah in German
yeah that's right that's terrible
Italian Guys silent he actually knows
geography
you can get away with the same things
are at different places with Americans
but uh Rachel where are you from
that area anywhere else that you could
say you're from
[Music]
just something around that doesn't mean
uh stereotyping I just want to uh make
my question no Seema stupid as everyone
thought it was
I know where you're from yeah yeah let's
hear it the cast of Orange Is the New
Black
are you Asian
you look like the Asian girl from that
yeah that's pretty good yeah yeah she's
half are you half oh yeah I'm half too
have what Filipino yeah white which mom
is so that's why
shut up
yes it is how it goes thank you she does
a good guess
it's like one of our main exports in the
Philippines is a five foot two vagina uh
what is her mother yeah yeah
it was she's got a great vagina
someone interview me
she's dead all right now now I feel like
Marco I'm making it sad
[Music]
really or I feel like adopt you so that
you don't become a suicide frankly my
daddy
thank you papa Frank
that's cool you're uh for half asian I
grew up in San Francisco a lot of Asians
there yeah
yeah
[Music]
okay what what kind of Asian
Chinese
and Jewish are you Jewish
you must really love saving money yeah
they compete good God how much money is
in your bank account I couldn't even
imagine how financially prepared I'd be
if those Chinese and Jewish
I'm Filipino in half Arkansas okay like
I'm broke
[Music]
we're not disposing finances on the
first date okay good good setting
boundaries yeah
uh Daniel what is uh something that you
would reveal on a first day that maybe
someone else wouldn't
have a reveal
uh I mean I'm a pretty open
so
how about
childhood trauma oh
yeah let's talk about it I mean if I had
any I would share honestly um he's as
privileged as he looks
who's your dad and what state is he a
senator of
uh yeah nothing like that just uh just a
finance guy did you have a golden
retriever going up I did not uh a couple
dollars
absolutely yeah thanks again privilege
what a [ __ ] for sure what a [ __ ] yeah
bro don't [ __ ] rub it in all right
dog
three of us did not get back yeah that's
typically how it goes when you're Asian
you just live a Loveless life
and overcompensate in other areas yeah
I know
So Daniel uh what do you love about
sports
um I don't know there's entertaining for
some reason do you think like maybe it
could be a trap and you could spend a
lot of energy and time and not see
anything so this will come out of it
um
well uh Rachel what is your like advice
do you have anything that you like to do
like uh what is that horoscopes
the female sports
nice
compatibility yo you know exactly how to
[ __ ] on his sports team yeah every man
needs that in his life a woman that just
bust his balls a little bit you know
what I mean that's good
yeah I don't think uh Daniel
really uh
do appreciate someone who bust your
balls
uh
multiple attitude
I haven't tried that though I'm guessing
it is
that ironed out
but no like a little a little attitude
and you know being able to like
oh so you like Puerto Rican girls
sure yeah sure
it's good
California and Asians are all a little
Puerto Rican they're a little
meaner than normal Asians are a little
tougher
there's not enough
um
what did you like about growing up in
SoCal as an Asian
um
oh the identity is just gonna come until
later so you could spread out the white
man perversions amongst the whole group
yeah it's like one every five
yeah like I got San Fernando Valley
cover
terrified
for me it was the opposite I grew up in
a redneck town
like one of five Asians so like I was
jealous of you Cali Asians because you
guys get to see other Asian people yeah
your identities came early yeah for sure
damn why is it so introspective on me
now I just need to shut the [ __ ] up this
is why I can't be with Asian women dude
they peel back your layers bro is that
why are you married a white lady yeah
they're very dominant they're very
docile and they can be trained not like
you Cali Asian women y'all are spicy
Daniel have you ever had uh relations
with an Asian woman
no
well tonight you're lucky
we're a condom bro or that baby will
come out like this dude
[Music]
let's go over the balls right now bud
huh does it go over the balls or no
I mean you can't load them in like
shotgun shells personally for me
my condoms slip off like a loose sock if
I don't pop my nards in there
you just gotta put it over the the
foreskin
that's all you really need it don't even
roll it just put it on like a little
yamaka
yeah there you go it did that for you
yeah
representation Marco what are you
writing down
notes boy yeah
[Music]
you should have said it out loud
yeah it's okay to be a predator
Marcus would like to read it out loud
give it to her give it to her so she can
read it out loud
this is what this man passed your date
today
[Music]
you want to read it
Marco said
oh Marco
that's good that you stopped where you
were it's okay he's not toasted five
star
that's awesome do you get a lot of that
you get a lot of people handing you
notes on buses and drawing you in public
places yeah my biggest fear is ending up
on somebody's Tick Tock because they
drew me on a pause
it's like such an invasion of privacy
how [ __ ] up would it be if somebody
was on a bus and just handed you a
picture of Mulan Mulan
or Jackie Chan
just somebody who doesn't even look like
her
I like that Panda from Kung Fu Panda
they're like you're the only one that
they tried on a different Asian girl on
the same bus and then it failed so it
was probably recycled hell yeah they can
use it he's just putting copies that one
picture and he's a ship see how he tries
to just keep in San Francisco you know
probably on the 8 bus going north into
the back and try it multiple times who's
who's Jewish on your mom or your dad yes
Dad obviously oh nice you knew this I
like the Chinese [ __ ] it feels good
that's my dead mom you're gonna go there
oh [ __ ] my mom's dead too dude we have
so much in common bro Rachel tap me the
[ __ ] up you're like the realest person
that's been on so far I don't think
anybody else y'all better sign the [ __ ]
up you got a top Rachel she's winning
the game in my brain right now I have a
little game up here you're just bombing
over the dead mom yeah
Michael's about to cheat on his wife
tonight
let me take this little rubber ring off
because I'm autistic and I lose my
wedding ring it's like a [ __ ] idiot
I'm just kidding that's like size
okay size one
what size ring do you think I have I
think it's like a nine uh
[Music]
yeah I mean I think uh that's awesome
I'm glad that uh you're gonna prove The
Stereotype wrong because he's an Asian
oh yeah Asian appearing Asian presenting
man yeah is with the white presenting
woman [ __ ] passing is what we call it
that uh it's always white women are uh
Asian women remember he grew up in a
redneck town so it's like the cell
painting the identity issues hey
whatever it takes right if you have to
hate yourself to [ __ ] a white woman I
say go ahead and do it you goddamn right
Mr Kim
this is what we have to do it's not as
easy for us as it is for you yeah uh but
no uh Asian men are doing fine you know
we got we got shank Chi
yeah that was dope I felt special
watching that
I felt represented it was our black
panther Daniel how does it feel to be a
minority
mistakes
learned
um I mean that childhood trauma stuff I
was like oh is that a thing with uh
oh childhood drama couldn't be me oh
yeah
that's awesome I'm like my daddy loves
me what's the hardest thing you've been
through
the hardest thing yeah
[ __ ] Tesla died inside the road
the Packers lost
Rachel tonight they won actually hell
yeah you didn't tell us uh I wanted to
kept it to myself yeah they kicked the
field goal away myself it's all good do
we want to check on the Cowboys this
guy's more autistic than Marco
um but yeah so anything difficult like
did you go to college did you uh
Dojo
yeah actually uh yeah I would never have
even considered the organizing it was a
very ambitious academically didn't care
too much it didn't happen to people
um I did go to school and get a degree I
guess there was a time in college where
I
injured my foot lost a job couldn't pay
rent had to sleep on a friend's couch
getting a third shift job in a warehouse
there we go there was saw a little
string of one mild young adult stress
yeah you worked in a warehouse all the
black dudes making fun of you I get it
it was rough good character building it
came in last I was joking
that's the only character the lacking
character through college
well hopefully everyone's kids will be
like you one day
you are The Shining golden example that
all the immigrants strive towards
emotionally healthy
just a little obsessive Sports which is
fine that's that's allowed in our
society really not obsessed which is you
were shaking dude you were [ __ ]
shaking you're like this you're like
[ __ ] Packers win the win never like
that dude overtime man how much money do
you have on the game any money in the
game I don't know what the [ __ ]
I wouldn't I definitely wouldn't bet uh
for the Packers this year yeah
who would they're the worst
Rachel so what big games do you keep up
with big games yeah like sports wise
um yeah I stopped paying attention to
sports
after I got a degree in sports wow of
all the people to have a degree in
sports I would have thought it'd be
Daniel
he looks like I want to go that's an
exercise science exercise science okay
the Assumption on gender is showing yeah
what sports were you studying
synchronized swimming or gymnastics
now because women are better at that
than the
um
no it's a degree in sport management
class
es we don't work in sports management
what do you guys do
I quit my job two months ago damn right
thank you how are you how am I feeling
lost
um confused
uh and slightly well traveled
wow taking care of yourself going on
vacations
that's cool why'd you quit why did I
quit
um you know sometimes we get tired of
men telling you what to do when they
don't know what they're doing tell me
about it
they're getting bossed around by
but yeah you were working in a male
dominated industry
and you're like I'm sick of these nerds
emotionally
unintelligent men
is there any other kind
or a bunch of not that I found
idiots
um
[Music]
uh I train athletes for their Sports
there you go you got out of that
warehouse I did yes congratulations
thanks I like how you're trying to say
you're not obsessed with sports
that's your job you do it like 40 hours
a week I'm more obsessed with science
than Sports I mean put it to sports
coolest thing to do science
um I mean like run faster jump higher
get stronger are there steroids involved
in that not online no are you legally
allowed to suppose um on anybody else's
end
anything
I'm not like okay dealers are you
allowed to disclose into someone else's
head sounds like you're shooting drugs
into someone's butt
[Music]
um
injecting roids into ass cheek so I'll
push it to the Limit plays in the
background
moves you to the Limit and he's like
it would be the soundtrack [ __ ] yeah
your your daily work week is just
Montage after montage somebody climbing
stairs and throwing both fists both
Fists in the air
the rocky references yeah for sure I did
that on the steps in Philadelphia
yeah did you do it yeah
uh mostly amateur
a little bit of professional here is
that the feeling are you happy I am can
you get paid enough for the most part
happy and
paid adequately yeah
I hate to play around with men
actually trading more females than males
so nice also the dreams concerning
problematic you need to do more squats
what sport do you specialize in
uh I guess track basketball volleyball
or whatever my biggest ones yeah you
need to do more squats
typically all the women that play those
have big butts
[Music]
volleyball
yeah those are all legs Sports truth
seems like you have a fetish promotes
glute growth
gluteus maximus
so uh yeah that sounds interesting would
you ever uh go to sports game with this
handsome guy maybe root for the Green
Bay Packers yeah
okay sure I mean where the tickets I
don't even know where the seats are I
don't do no sleeps anymore
um I guess we'll have to get some better
ones though if their 50-yard line we're
all considered okay
no uh you know anybody in the front
office or do I have to make calls I do
not know anybody in the front office no
I've actually never been to a Packers
game
what were you doing your whole childhood
what was Dad doing the um
not that wealthy
wow that's a little one game a season
you sit up in the 400s
I could go back in time you know I guess
I can try to convince my parents maybe
that's your childhood trauma yeah it's
the worst of all traumas did you ever go
to Disneyland or anything as a kid
uh no we took a we drove to Florida and
we stayed at like a friend's house there
that was like the version of yeah I was
like our you know was that very budgeted
vacation well that's close that's close
to Disney World I misjudged you you're a
poor white you would consider you grew
up with poor White
lower middle class probably yeah
not poor enough I mean I wasn't going
hungry
yeah not poor enough
you're basically in the one percent
the bottom one percent of white people
top
that's the top 10 of Filipino people
[Music]
well thank you for coming on this date
and hopefully uh you know this date is
as successful as your Green Bay Packers
tonight
you can uh
put on the condoms you know the proper
way
[Music]
we got another couple coming up yeah who
could it be
it's none other than
[Music]
Kenton a straight female named Kenton
it's a real person's name what's called
yesterday there's comes Canton giving up
her Canton y'all give it up for cancer
and the man is named Mike L as in gonna
get L today as a blade
[Music]
like L and Kenton
geez you're a big ass [ __ ]
what minute starting now
good how are you good good thanks for
asking what
uh I'm just here for the weekend this is
Mexico on vacation where are you from uh
from Detroit okay from there once it was
fun how'd you like it
um it was in the middle of like the city
being really
good so like literally like the couple
of houses for sale
2010 13 14.
yeah I'm gonna drive around like every
house is abandoned everyone yeah
yeah you know burned down crackhead
living with it it was Iowa to St Louis I
grew up here so it was nice that these
are like a lot of burn places here
crackheads I know it's just everyone all
household and it's not enough houses
[Music]
and time we're giving up for Mike L and
Kenton
put on a date
they talked about crackheads
is this something you have a lot of
experience with Mike L
what was the biggest uh interaction you
had with a crackhead
uh I beat the [ __ ] out of it
oh dude I knew it you guys probably
throw those things like darts over there
like it was a it was like you know
before I was 21.
I gave the dude you know uh 10 bucks
like you know keep the change give me a
five dollar bottle or whatever and then
I [ __ ] go to you know around the bank
to take a piss and uh I see the [ __ ]
going so I [ __ ] chase sets down
whooped his ass
for 10 bucks yeah well I mean dude that
was like I didn't have a lot of money
back then you know and like but why are
you sending homeless people on errands
for you it was it was in front of the
liquor store that's where they like to
hang out you're like I I don't want to
go in no he had a little operation you
were underage oh he was underage and he
sent a crackhead in in the crackhead and
ran off with the bag well that's it's
called the old Switcheroo where I'm from
here I had that happen to me too you
don't give them any denomination over a
10.
it just is you they see that 10 dude
that sweat starts trickling down
they'll take it they can't handle that
they don't they're not used to seeing
that much money at once instead of crack
for two days yes or 30 minutes if you're
where I'm from
Kenton you said uh what were you gonna
say
see what part of Arkansas are you from
I'm not from Arkansas I'm from Virginia
my family yeah my white side of my
family's from Arkansas what part uh the
bullet part is from our [ __ ] Newport
yeah exactly Newport is gross
it's where the cigarettes are named
after oh that's Reynolds that's North
Carolina
red old cigarettes yeah but I'm also
from Newport News in Virginia there's a
lot of Newports going on yeah
the only part that isn't new is your old
white wife
instead of Old Port there's only one
little boat that goes in it on so I'm
fine with that well you know Marco likes
to watch boats going to well he can sub
to my only fans then okay it's very a
very lucrative Asian male white female
only fans yeah they said you are in
Detroit when I wasn't doing so well so
you've been there in the last 100 years
it doesn't really narrow it down it's
still not doing that well
uh yeah I think so do people just go
there to laugh or feel better about
where they're from
Jesus
what are you doing in Detroit
um I have a Junior Olympics there when I
was in high schooler very in track oh
I think it was at Eastern Michigan
University did you ever work with the
sports guy that kept looking at a sports
game while he was working with you we
worked together oh you didn't know him
yeah okay nice I do the [ __ ] all the
time too
what are you into
okay
yeah you look like you'd be into
football you look like a character from
Remember The Titans
go back up here black people aren't that
bad after all
right you look like you're related to
the somebody that dinosaurs that come
from the 90s
it's a deep cut I guess
do you uh did you used to play football
yes what was your fondest memory of were
you and all the football guys going out
and just making a Ruckus no I'm being
like it's just Jersey Jason
what is that Jersey Chasers
chuckle [ __ ] for football
that is [ __ ] some chicks from New
Jersey
[Music]
well that sounds a lot better uh Jersey
Chaser is nice in high school or college
or both
wow
nice tackle people
have you ever had to tackle someone
besides the crackhead that one time yeah
that's a typical weekend in Detroit you
guys win the game go out get [ __ ]
drunk and beat up homeless crackheads
[ __ ] yeah dude
but uh
that's about it
hell yeah dude you're [ __ ] you know
how to party I bet yeah the Forest Grove
Sports jet sweater on
you definitely know how to party
I feel like you crush kegs like normal
soda cans it's liquor I'm just trying to
hear cheese
all I drink is 17 beers tonight damn
right
as soon as I get going I can't stop you
are a [ __ ] moose of a human dude you
know I don't you know I can go once upon
drinking but when I do something goes on
in my head I'm like yeah CTE
kicks in dude just gotta start pounding
those [ __ ] whatever you drink Detroit
[Music]
Kenton uh dude are you uh are you a big
party or do you do you go out and do
Molly or something
oh
26 now
it's good old 27.
Janice Joplin age I went to college on
the East Coast had the time of my life
rest of my life every weekend but it was
worth me excellent that's a motto over
there every weekend we died
that's crazy we're we're on the east
coast of Jersey Shore
[Music]
or the the cities
was the hardest drug you've ever done
I don't know
cocaine Molly and cocaine yes those are
two good ones that's as far as I would
ever go oh okay and I don't do this
anymore anymore okay we had a couple of
dabblings but we're done now yeah we're
26 you're 26 yeah 26 year old Kenton
does he do Molly or cocaine he goes it's
good gross is good I bet I think you're
like Euphoria like Zendaya you're like
you're doing drugs when you're at 12.
absolutely not I was like being the last
person in the apartments when I was in
high school I was so like
track it was like my world so yeah well
track was your drug yeah just running
away from all those yummy drugs could
have been just sitting in your couch
getting high they're watching the future
watching Mike L beat up a crackhead
do it for you damn right what a
gentleman give it up for mine dude bye
she's gonna go on our Rampage tonight
it's got a whole row of them outside
yeah yeah under that bridge
the homeless man homeless person Donkey
Kong over here
uh so have you ever been homeless
how's your how's your uh how's your life
after college or did you uh did you get
a job right away
uh yeah
and then what did what did you do for
your excitement after the football days
were over
uh well I moved around a lot and moved
to San Francisco like Daly City
I can't imagine that I can't imagine the
last guest we had in San Francisco
Rachel but I feel like no I lived there
I live with my buddy in an apartment
where like it's his bedroom and you
gotta walk by like in his bedroom to
[ __ ] take a piss basically and like
he always had [ __ ] over so
dude would just be railings
you've smelled many smells
oh God
hopefully you lifted the dishes
[Music]
clay
uh that's cool and how old are you now
you could be anywhere from 22 to 74.
that's 31. 31. so you're an adult now
you definitely know too Molly no all
right what's the hardest drug you've
ever done Michael
hell yeah a match made in heaven a Coke
and Molly and Denton and Mike
though you guys should just relapse [ __ ]
it it's done tonight
it's party like it's 2013
.
I'm so nice [ __ ] yeah you're Wild
I was popping Xanax in high school
I had a white girl that scratch my head
in health class and feed me blue
footballs
did you ever steal anything when you're
on Xanax no not that I remember
because you don't remember anything on
Xanax so perhaps
I'll be stealing [ __ ]
on Xanax
museums you guys ever do any
psychedelics
hell yes germ's an acid yes DMT
no DMT
you guys should do DMT together tonight
that'd be awesome I'm done with drugs
me neither but whoa that's crazy you're
telling me it's intense I only do
psychedelics I'm sober but I still do
mushrooms
well they're good for your brain
actually yeah if you're a fat depressed
Asian person like me yeah they're really
good
so we're on South Lamar do you live
Kenton
West Austin West Austin holy [ __ ] 27 is
what you're really making in life holy
[ __ ] no it's an apartment okay it'll be
caves I grew up there actually oh you're
a native austinite
it's a city we've got street signs and
everything I've been looking for
somewhere to live so I looked at bks I
heard it was cheap
sure okay never mind
so you grew up there it must have been
like out in the booties back in the day
it was actually only 15 minute drive to
downtown back then but now we have like
so much traffic and so many people that
it's like 30 months yeah I think it
would have been beautiful to farm
country where do you where did East
Austin do you live
Detroit Detroit oh you're visiting I'm
sorry guys Hans is a malfunctioning hold
on let me go back here into this panel
and reset him
so you're from Detroit yes oh hell yeah
wow good for you man Detroit is fun uh
how why why did you come here
vacation
that's fun
do you like stand-up comedy I do this is
my first time in Austin experiencing it
but hell yeah what do you usually
experience instead of college
when I was in college I played in New
York City
Jesus Christ your life is awesome
I wish I looked like Zendaya
[Music]
it's pretty easy Hans has a joke about
that
yeah I would love to be uh Michael's
girlfriend and he did carry us both on
his shoulders
pay for everything
um but yeah no I think it's good to be a
man I'm a happy new man uh that's cool
you went to New York you had a rich
older boyfriend
um
it wasn't Rich he was just old
how old was he and how old were you
we had a 13 year old Jesus Christ
that's a big one jeez 13. so you were 20
he was 33. what we met and then we
started dating when I was sick so
it was Jesus's age you couldn't eat a
drink
wow what does that mean I don't know did
he heard you
Jesus Christ
oh that's cool I hope everything's okay
blink twice
uh Michael what's your relationship
status like do you uh how was your
dating life in Detroit like you meet a
lot of black women no I'm single and no
I don't get a lot of work
[Music]
yeah so if you pick them up or sell them
tackle them
I don't know if I'm looking for them you
know if that's the case
uh my gal so yeah that's cool so you're
single uh you're uh you you didn't
settle down with any of those Jersey
Chasers
no no you know they come and get a
there's always another Jersey yeah yeah
but you guys just use them and hang them
from the rafters
what are you doing now
uh I I just call Weed hell yeah
cooking up that Detroit Kush baby butter
oil
this shit's called Ford plan
that's nice
well that's depressing Mike no one wants
to hear about that no that's just I was
just kidding uh thank you guys for going
on a date and I really appreciate you
Mike Allen Kenton and thank you so much
hell yeah that was awesome I like one
last date but we got one more straight
female it would be a waste to let her go
to waste uh we got Brie like the bread
coming up three give it up a Brie y'all
where you at girl oh here she is
favorite of the show here he comes
shadow
[Music]
he's coming around
did you sign up
yeah
um I'm sorry to get to you maybe channel
will suck and then we can bring you in
as a replacement
Shadow and Bree everybody
[Music]
nobody knew what I was talking about
Tampa's going to be like a pretty like
palm trees and yeah yeah
that's great oh wow I just got hundreds
of marijuana
oh really well it doesn't work together
I can hide my weed here and everything
I smoke a lot you probably don't want to
keep it away well that works out too
so don't know me you smoke a lot
smoke weed but government
so what else about it and time give it
up for free and Shadow
[Music]
oh you're already trying to move your
marijuana plants into our house in the
first stage look for a new spot for them
are you here for a date or to run away
from the FBI a little bit of both you
know you're looking for right now two
birds one stone yeah there you go Bree
uh you uh love the colors of Austin
obviously you're not talking about the
people very White City not very diverse
oh man buildings are better than people
they don't hurt you
I mean we're awesome yeah
except for Marco you gotta check your
secret family
so Bree what's uh what's what's your
favorite part of Austin so far
besides shadow
the little the little metal things we
all have on the storm drains that have
frogs on it that say no litter
everything
colorful white and blue and green little
no they're just basic ones
I have no idea I just got here last week
is
yeah that's very specific
very quirky such an obscure detail in
somebody it's a little artistic show
tonight
whoa whoa calm down Shadow I feel like I
feel like you're pretty autistic
yourself with your Guardians of the
Galaxy jackets
I feel like this there's a lot of
compatibility right here in this date I
feel like
hell yeah there's a lot of compatibility
in this data I feel like you guys would
be casted for like a comic bookstore
employee porn
yeah
and you're also dressed like a link from
Legend of Zelda Liv Tyler from Lord of
the Rings
oh yeah
shadow
um what uh what do you what is the most
nerdy thing that you're entered into
I play a lot of video games is that
nerdy I play a lot of Mortal Kombat
can you do it like an impression of your
favorite finishing move like the sound
that makes oh I'll tell you who's your
main it's like my finishing move is like
doggy style a lot of times it's over
with but what bend over here
man I just get it over with
uh no where are we heading what noise
does that make
you know actually I play on mute because
it's so [ __ ] annoying because it's a
lot of
Photoshop
as white people beatboxing for you that
was BP fighting that's cool I like that
uh Brie what's your favorite video game
have never played a video game in my
life ever and they just gave you those
glasses
you play what Pokemon go Pokemon go
still yeah
what's the best Pokemon that you've
caught so far where did you catch it
[Music]
homeless mom outside of the Arts
building
a crackhead that Mike L beat up crack
him on I have a lucky Gyarados that I
got
[Music]
give it up her [ __ ] Gyarados
a lot of Digimon fans and all this I
know geez get over it you lost
it's cool what's the nerdiest thing that
you do do
you besides Pokemon videos
[Music]
what do you do for work
no way hell yeah I was about to say
my vision comes true
no I'm just a nanny
that's kind of so you do porn
your body yeah
anyways
what do you do though
you're a nanny okay where are you Nanny
again
grown men in diapers
oh yeah Google gaga wipe the poop off my
balls you know what I'm saying
no I don't all right okay I don't know
what you do it's very confusing I do my
best okay well you've done a great job
becoming outfits that look like you made
them yourself at a Renaissance Fair yeah
it's very beautiful you know and uh yeah
Shadow you look like you're trying to
pretend to be uh Chris Pratt for Legends
you look like uh somebody took all the
you look like silver I'm sorry one
second man
I don't speak English English is my
fourth language
yeah Twin Dragons right now we're making
salad
you look like all the clerics characters
were putting in AI
there we go I got it out I got it out
if comic book it was more uh successful
I would refer you as me but nobody would
know what I'm talking about no one still
knows what you're talking about
um
I uh I sell cannabis classes okay you're
gonna teach people how to smoke weed
yeah some people don't in hell right you
know they just hold it in their mouth
you got to tell them
see you get it see not everybody knows
that [ __ ] I certify you in that there
you go
you see the government involved with
that no they actually are well not the
way I want them to be Yeah Austin Texas
the city of made-up jobs
yeah who's paying to do this yeah people
who don't know how to smoke weed wow you
know like old people oh nice people into
it well Memaw you hold the bong like
this yeah I see no actually I I think
people want to work in the Cannabis
industry like what what Indica is what
sativa is like what's it recommend for
certain elements that type of stuff so
that whole thing about inhaling was just
you just made that up yeah I'm trying to
be funny you know just trying to do this
job with them does anyone ever fail in
your class actually
you know
so yeah no uh so we give him like three
chances to pass that Subs still do not
pass yeah but we do have a live class
that's kind of like more like a
participation class and everybody gets
into that one but you know the online
classes we do have failures yeah it's
crazy a whole bunch of a loser do you
have to beat a flunk out of wheat School
me
I can't smoke weed gotta inhale after
yourself
I mean you clearly love when you're
dressed like we eat tonight
talk about women like their joints
Shadow yeah
Shadow so where does the O come from
what is that you want my last name it's
my last name Chad Shadow well it's a
long last name so I thought it was just
Chad and Spanish yeah
there's an Asian tea that's a shadow Tea
Ceremony have you guys familiar with
this
now
well give it up for it Shadow and break
they went on a date hell yeah
fortunately we're out of time thank you
guys so much for coming anything you
want to plug Michael uh you guys can
follow me on Instagram at [ __ ] sweat
c-h-i-n-k-y sweats she said it not me
thank you guys so much for coming give
it up for Michael Ridley [ __ ] sweat on
Instagram thank you guys
[Music]